I want to just kind of explain how to
use the cpctc a concept and in some
classes in some books they call it CPC F
so let me just see if I can show you
what I mean let's say we have two
triangles like so say that we can prove
that these triangles are congruent like
this entire triangles congruent to this
entire triangle meaning if I take some
scissors I cut it out I place it on here
they're gonna be exactly the same we're
gonna match up perfectly if I can do
that then what that means is that every
part of this triangle meaning all three
angles and all three sides
the ones that they match up with or
correspond with they're going to be
congruent so first step is to prove the
triangles congruent then everything that
matches up or corresponds will be
congruent also and that's what the cpctc
tells us okay so in this proof they're
giving us some hints here they're
telling us that segment RT is congruent
to segment V T and what I like to do is
I like to just mark it on the diagram so
I don't have to remember to my mind I
can just see it visually and they also
tell us that angle R is congruent to
angle these so again I'm just gonna make
a little mark here to show that these
two angles are congruent okay and then
what we're trying to prove is that angle
U is congruent to angle s okay but the
first thing you want to do is we want to
prove these two triangles congruent now
if you've been working with the
congruent triangles chapter in your
geometry class you learned that there's
five different ways to prove triangles
congruent you can use the side side side
a side angle side angle side angle an
angle angle side or a hypotenuse leg if
they're both right triangles right so
which one of these can we use to prove
that these two triangles are congruent
well you can see here that these two
angles are vertical angles they're going
to be congruent to one another so that's
going to be part of our proof so we're
going to go ahead and show that angle
STR put that down here angle STR is
congruent to angle let's see UTV UTV and
the reason would be vertical angle
theorem
okay I'm just abbreviating now you can
see that these two triangles are
congruent if I was to take this triangle
and rotate it like 180 degrees they're
gonna match up angle side angle angle
side angle so you can see that's this
one right here and even though it's just
three components it allows us to prove
that
entire triangle is congruent to the
other entire triangle so let's go ahead
and write that down so we have triangle
RTS is congruent to triangle
let's see vtu now the order is important
notice how when our TS vtu I went from
this angle with one mark one arc to this
angle with two arcs to this angle with
no arcs and then back so I went one two
zero one two zero so I'm going around so
that when I match them up they're in the
same relative position to one another
okay and the reason for that is the
angle side angle triangle congruence
theorem will just write angle side angle
okay now that we know that the triangles
are congruent we can go to our last
statement okay which is what we're
trying to prove and that's that angle U
is congruent to angle s and that's by
the cpctc
once you prove the triangles are
congruent we take this triangle we
rotate it everything that matches up you
can see angle s is going to match up
with angle u those are going to be
congruent as well because we've already
proved that the entire triangles are
congruent so the only thing that I
really left off here are the Givens
okay and so we usually put that
somewhere near the beginning of the
proof that's what I normally do just to
get out of the way I would put these two
statements right here you can see this
is only about four snaps some of the
proofs that you're gonna be doing a
little bit longer but this one was
little bit shorter we just had to show
the triangles congruent and then the
parts that match up will be congruent as
well so I hope this helped you
understand how to work with the cpctc or
the cpcf depending on how your teacher
uses that acronym and subscribe to the
channel check out some the other videos
on Mario's math tutor and YouTube
channel and I look forward to seeing the
future videos I'll talk to you soon